[Music]
we have mentioned in our monologue li
obtained new Ukrainian documents from
Rudy Guiliani now the Democrats earlier
today they actually went into a briefing
room they thought they're gonna get
impeachable evidence on the president
what they got was information that hurt
their cause and showed about oh the
Democrats and yeah the DNC in the
Hillary Clinton campaign yeah they were
colluding with Ukraine in 2016 and yeah
they're admitting they tried to help
Hillary Clinton and they're also
admitting the information they provided
well had an impact in the race because
they took down Paul Manafort with that
information we also have Rudy Giuliani
is threatening to sue along with the
president and the president we now
learned that former New York City Mayor
Rudy Giuliani interviewed the fired
prosecutor by Biden and that would be
the prosecutor Shokan he's here to
explain all of it mr. mayor well
Democrats had a had a bad dream today
because they thought they was all going
to come to fruition tonight it did not
you interviewed Shokan and you may sue
that's a lot to digest well I mean what
what happened today is the the big
announcement yesterday was the idea the
State Department was going to go over
and give all these secret documents to
to the committee and the committee I
guess they were sitting there figuring
out how they could do impeachment based
on nothing and what they got shoved down
their throats is a complete total
absolutely terrific prosecutorial
outline of why Joe Biden is so guilty
it's a joke I even have to describe it
to you what I did first of all it
demonstrates that I process I prosecuted
well they're members of 40 insolate I
investigated all of this starting in
November of 2018 and I finished it by
March 28 2019 now why is that
significance that's significant because
all of this was done while the Muller
investigation was still pending
while I was seeking in the best
tradition of being a lawyer a defense
lawyer to vindicate my client this is
information that was given to me I
didn't go looking for Joe Biden the
Ukrainians brought me substantial
evidence of Ukrainian collusion with
Hillary Clinton the DNC George Soros
George Soros's company they put it in my
lab they came and gave me testimony I
wrote it out I had a professional
investigator make FBI 302 of it
eventually it was John John Solomon who
should get a Pulitzer Prize by the way
put them all on tape so it's all
memorialized on videotapes so this is
solid as it can get and I interviewed
them in one case I interviewed Lutz anko
so badly he thought he was being
cross-examined I don't I don't accept
the I didn't do what this phony
whistleblower did this phony
whistleblower is giving hearsay evidence
he says I'm not a direct witness okay
useless pal you're not a direct witness
goodbye I have what's called an
affidavit here this is not what the
whistleblower did this is under oath
it's signed under penalties of perjury
by Victor Shogun Viktor Shogun has told
me he's more than willing to come to
America and testify before Congress and
point the finger at Joe Biden and his
son and basically support what the
president said today their corrupted sin
this is so obvious it's a it's like you
the nose on your face
Shawn they the the Ukrainian oligarch
Oslo chefs key didn't pay millions for
hunter buy Biden's non-existent skill he
paid millions to buy the vice
president's office and it was a good
deal for cesky he got hunter Biden off
the hook
he got Soros his company out of jeopardy
and he got to come back to the Ukraine
and keep his five billion dollars just
for merely giving up maybe 100 million
he is actually going around Ukraine
saying it was well worth it to spend the
money to do it if anybody would care to
investigate they could find everything I
just said except the FBI didn't
investigate for a year and a half the
Justice Department didn't investigate a
year and a half my witnesses were afraid
to go to the FBI and the Justice
Department which actually to me was like
living in an alternate universe because
I you know I prosecuted people far more
dangerous and far more difficult to
catch these idiots
and I did it with the effort what a
great FBI couldn't have done it without
the FBI and I'm so disappointed at how
Comey has corrupted the FBI and at least
on the surface that hasn't been reformed
the way it should and I hate to say that
but I could not have given this to the
FBI in early 2018 and Bill Barr wasn't
there yet so they wouldn't go to the
Justice Department so I gave it to the
State Department I turned it over to
them I gave them my witness notes oh my
god I was hoping they'd come back and
interview me I was so happy when the
secretary told me they were going to
investigate for six months I saw no sign
of an investigation they never
interviewed me without my knowledge
maybe they interviewed Shokan and lured
senko and i assume they did but there's
no evidence they did and if they didn't
something's wrong and it's been turned
over and out of the FBI
and if you don't interview an eyewitness
who wants to go under oath and wants to
be a confrontational accuser which is
what if the Constitution requires you
got to be faced with your accusers he's
willing to face Joe Biden and say you're
guilty you participated in a bribe of my
president
you got me thrown out so there's a Soros
the case against the billionaire in the
case against your son and everybody
knows you're corrupt oh and by the way
this is eerily similar to what happened
in China Mike it's a pattern and let's
go take a look now at James Biden and
how he was selling the office of Senator
when this guy was back in the Senate
this reminds me of a pattern of criminal
conduct that spanned over about three
decades that the somnolent washington
press corps just let happen and didn't
look at and if they had picked it up in
any stage of the way they could have
protected us in this country against
this kind of horrible corruption that
makes a mockery of us in Ukraine and
China mr. mayor
so you interviewed show listening all of
this if Donald Trump jr. did any of this
if Donald Trump did this they might
actually have their first real charge
against the president we have political
we have all the evidence that the DNC
and Hillary
campaign colluded with Ukraine the
media's deaf dumb and stupid as they
always are in corrupt we have you
interviewed Shokan we know why he was
fired he was told why he was fired he's
now set at five separate times that he
was fired because he was interviewing
and investigating Biden's corrupt son
you're right if he was fired for being
corrupt excuse me I don't mean this is
an insult but almost everybody in in the
Ukrainian government would be fired I
mean if he is corrupt he's not very good
at it he's quite poor I know all these
guys look cinco's got a lot of dough big
cars lots of money Shokan is living in
the village he's living in the cottage
he's actually hiding and scared out of
his mind that they're gonna kill him
because I mean I can't this is not up to
us to investigate but if you think the
President of the Ukraine let out one of
the richest people let him get away with
five million dollars without what do
they say in The Godfather
picking his beak or or filling his beak
or I can't remember that expression well
taking his portion of it if you don't
think poroshenko got big millions for
this then you shouldn't be in the
investigatory business - mr. mayor were
running out of time
you say you made soup who well we're
looking at a very very serious lawsuit
Adam Schiff kind of advanced that
lawsuit today with the with the
possibility that he had advanced
knowledge and orchestrated this newest
non knowledge no first-hand knowledge
therefore should be ignored
whistleblower in fact he would have been
ignored until they changed the rules
none of his testimony is admissible in
court it's all hearsay every bit of
shoka's testimony is admissible in court
but they don't interview soakin actually
so can testifies to real corruption this
guy testifies to half of everything he
says about me here is false my meeting
with your Ermac was not set up because
of the conversation you know why idiot
because it took the set up before the
conversation the two people he said I
called I never called one of them I
wouldn't have called because he was put
on the list of corrupt people that I
shouldn't talk to there and I happen to
have independent knowledge of that so he
doesn't know what he's talking about
with regard to me there are apparent
indications I could point out seven or
eight where he
lying or at least so he may not be lying
he's relying on other people maybe they
lied to him that's why hearsay evidence
is it admissible
shokhin has direct evidence Luke has
direct evidence Kalia nook has direct
evidence wood Senko has direct evidence
bush tereshchenko has direct evidence I
have six witnesses who can give direct
admissible evidence of Russian Ukrainian
coercion not Russian collusion
participation in the steel dossier with
phony information the creation of false
evidence and a very clear corruption
scheme by the vice-president of our
United States and that has to be
vindicated and all of it was exposed
before he was a candidate for president
and it's not because he's a candidate
for president because he was a corrupt
disgraceful vice president who disgraced
our country in the Ukraine and in China
and they're still talking about how
corrupt he is and how stupid we are for
not catching it it has to be vindicated
to the honor of the United States of
America he disgraced us if you don't
react to that you have no sense of honor
or dignity we will stay on it mr. mayor
thank you